lo que voy a querer en este vídeo es
generalizar la idea que vimos en el
vídeo anterior es decir lo que nosotros
llamamos la vez pasada el método de los
discos y este método lo que me ayuda a
encontrar es el volumen de las figuras
que salen al girar una función alrededor
del eje de las equis y la idea que hay
detrás es exactamente la idea que vimos
en el ejercicio anterior así que te
recomiendo que no te memorizar la
fórmula porque si tú te memorizar la
fórmula nunca vas a saber de dónde viene
así que recordemos un poco lo que vimos
en el vídeo pasado nosotros tomábamos la
función y es igual x cuadrada y ésta que
estoy dibujando era su gráfica recuerdan
ahora lo que voy a hacer es generalizar
lo y decir que esta es la función y es
igual a efe de x y ojo ahora f x puede
ser cualquier función que nosotros
queramos y la vez pasada íbamos desde x
igual a cero hasta x igual a 2
ahora para hacerlo más general no voy a
tomar que vamos desde el punto x
igualada hasta el punto x igual y bueno
sacamos entonces ahora el volumen de
esta figura pues lo que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado fue sacarlo por medio de
discos y en este disco lo más importante
era obtener el radio de este círculo
pero como nosotros estamos generalizando
entonces no va a ser x cuadrada el radio
el radio va a ser fx y entonces el área
de la cara de este disco va a ser igual
a pi que multiplica a la función f x
elevada al cuadrado y esta es el área de
la cara de este disco ahora que ya
tenemos el área de la cara pues entonces
podemos sacar el volumen el volumen va a
ser esto mismo multiplicado por el ancho
pero el ancho o el grosor en este caso y
siempre es de equis y bueno después lo
que hacíamos era tomar la suma de todos
estos discos desde a hasta b tomamos la
suma de estos discos y además tomábamos
el límite cuando de x se hacía más y más
y más pequeño por lo tanto teníamos una
suma infinita de discos muy delgados
y eso no es otra cosa que tomar la
integral y bueno si un día te preguntan
oye de dónde sacaste esta fórmula pues
ya lo puedes explicar porque fx era el
radio de este disco por lo tanto todo
esto que tenemos aquí simple
esencialmente es el área del disco y
después multiplicamos por el grosor y
para finalizar tomamos la integral en
todo el intervalo desde a hasta b y
acabamos